bonsoir robert pétillot merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france on
imagine que vous attendez cette soirée
avec beaucoup d'impatience
il ya beaucoup d'enjeu pour vous ce soir
dans ce jeu il détaille ce soir il ya
encore beaucoup de délégués à la
californie à 500 délégués des états
comme la chine qui s'est tu as déjà à
presque 100 délégués donc nous pourrions
voir un gagnant des primaires en
fonction de ce qui se produit ce soir
vous ce soir une certaine manière on va
clairement connaître celui qui
affrontera donald trump heures en
novembre prochain on peut dire ça on
s'est un petit peu quand même précipité
comme nos conclusions
cela aurait trop tôt pour en tirer les
conclusions
surtout parce que nous avons encore joe
biden qui est qui participent à la
course et qui va avoir de bons résultats
aussi des états unis il est encore
d'aller sand qui va être populaire en
qualifs californie ou dans le nord-est
et on en a aussi
l'ancien maire de new york michael qui
est milliardaire qui a défoncé nommément
d'argent dans cette campagne
donc nous ne savons pas quels effets
vont avoir les millions de dollars qu'il
a défoncé pour sa consoeur accompagne
alors on le sait en tout cas que bernie
sanders pour le moment et est très
favoris je pense qu'il est dix points
d'avancé par rapport au deuxième et
effectivement joe biden qui après sa
victoire en caroline du sud a été
revigorée pour vous il y aura vraiment
désormais quand même un suspense les dés
ne sont pas jetés justement en faveur de
bernie sanders
pas du tout je pense que panis 1 2 s'en
sort très bien avec une minorité d
électeurs américains
mais il faut comprendre qu'il a gagné
25% de la vôtre a highway est un homme
j'ai aussi un faible pourcentage donc la
majorité du parti ne soutient pas 112
donc dans la course entre baidu
descendeur cela va être difficile pour
en d3 de se démarquer et d'avoir le
nombre de délégués dont ils ont besoin
pour avoir l'investiture tout de suite
michael bloomberg beaucoup l'avaient
donné perdant lors de son entrée on
débat il y a dix jours environ vous vous
pensez qu'il a encore des chances parler
de ses dollars qu'il a investi on sait
combien c'est très important lors d'une
campagne aux états unis
pas de chance de gagner mais il a une
opportunité des brawn et de la course
qui a du mal à récolter des fonds et
donc à des n'a dépensé que 4000 dollars
en californie par exemple michael
vineberg pourtant a dépensé plus de 10
millions et 10 millions de dollars
beaucoup risquent aucun autre candidat
alors le rock
voudrais tu peux jouer dans la course et
de d'empêcher d'un essaim d'avoir une
victoire absolue
les votes sont des styles vrai en
fonction du pourcentage de là vous que
l'individu obtient donc un bon mec va à
resortir deuxième place tant qu'ils
avaient acquis cet état dans une défense
beaucoup d'agents de cuivre il va
diviser la vôtre ce qui va aider
pas étonnant donc bloomberg en forme de
d'arbitré il ya aussi eu d'autres
protagonistes qui ont joué un rôle un
pit beauty djédjé amy klobuchar qui ont
tous de jeter l éponge plutôt en faveur
pour le coup de joe biden tout ça
tout à fait actuellement 1 minnesota qui
est l'état d' aimer corruption il y à
des publicités et des coachs à claude
jacky pour soutenir
pas étonnant j'ai pensé nous voyons que
les modérés du parti uni derrière un
candidat qui parle d'une et cela va
l'aider à prendre le dessus sur sanders
et cela représente entre environ 35% de
de tout tout et voit rien silence qui se
fait remarquer si j'ose dire c'est celui
de barack obama
pourquoi ne s'exprime t-il pas sur ces
primaires barack obama selon vous nous
avons vu par la commande est aussi
hillary clinton bill clinton qui sont
restés silencieux quant à cette course
et je pense que c'est surtout parce
qu'ils veulent être en position pour
prêter des soutiens à celui qui est au
rsa en premier elle n'est pas faire des
choix à ce stade de la course
les deux anciens présidents en plus coup
deux influents sur la partie et ils ne
veulent pas être vus en tant que les
personnes qui vont avoir une influence
en faveur de dans certains candidats ils
veulent unir le parti et je pense que ce
n'est pas ce n'est pas c'est assez
souvent que de l'ancien président agi de
cette façon nous avons vu par le passé
que des choses par exemple il y a eu des
anciens présidents qui ne sont pas
exprimés les anciens président essaye de
rester à l'écart et de ne pas exprimer
le soutien en faveur d'un candidat ou un
autre revers pâtir vous êtes stratège
démocrate qu'elles sont c'est ma
dernière question vos attentes
ce soir
c'est que nous avons à y partager baden
varois de bons résultats dans le sud où
il y à des populations au milan et à
l'afro américaine à arlington en
virginie
oklahoma et s'être je pense que il y a
beaucoup de chance que c est à vos côtés
pour des parisiens
ça ne doit pas avoir de bons résultats
au nord marc ce qui s'est vraiment cette
menace auteurs il va bien s'en sortir
danser et à l'a1 est important va être
le texas synthes a beaucoup de soutien
entre parmi les communautés hispano
latine ici ils n'arrivent à avoir
beaucoup de crack et beaucoup de voix au
texas
cela va beaucoup l'aider alors je pense
que l'état les taxes qu'il faut regarder
ce soir ce texte pour déterminer qui va
avoir ses chances de gagner
si paris remporte un texte alors nous
avons demain matin nous allons nous
allons voir nous allons voir que cela va
être difficile
merci beaucoup robert petit est d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur rt france
pour notre rubrique vu de l'extérieur
merci à vous